i want to switch gears though i'll
switch gears all right and talk about
the two-time mvp
defensive player of the year this year
and mvp
giannis getting it done
so uh
hey man how you feel about it you know
we saw what happened they lost to the
miami heat in five games
but he had a dominant
regular season he had a dominant regular
season how do you feel about it this mvp
award
i mean i just don't like where you
started to be honest with you you know i
mean it's at this you start you
in the same breath you start in the
wrong place and then you put this this
this weird emphasis these
italics letters around regular season
it's like you know something there's
something under that i'm i'm reading
tone i'm reading inflection it was a
regular season it's like how you feel
about it like how am i supposed to feel
about a guy that was the expected
two-time mvp went but what 30 14 and six
joins jordan and olajuwon as the only
players to win defensive player and mvp
in the same season had the highest
player efficiency rating in nba history
i believe look i'm not a numbers guy but
i used to play one on tv every now and
then i mean
field goal percentage
you lead league and field goal
percentage at the rim and as the closest
defender i mean so this was expected i
mean look
he wanted a bit of a landslide i think
he had 85 first place votes to 16 for
lebron so i feel fantastic for giannis a
great
personal story a great success story
continues to get even better as he gets
better and i just hope there aren't
people
who have any kind of mixed reaction
around his uh receiving so there you go
so so this is about to have the playoff
conversation and it should be an award
for the entire season not just the
regular season is that where we're going
with this
can a professor from marist college call
on a student i heard you shouting
yourself out yesterday you and jay
mcmanus giving all that love all that
free advertising to marist uh in their
sports program out there listen um
one i want to say this because i i love
you know i love in the nba i love nba
history and so
since the mvp awards started i think
they started giving it out like 65 years
ago
and just looking through the list of mvp
winners i think basketball may be the
only sport that can say this
basketball does not do one-hit wonders
when it comes to the mvp like football i
was giving one of our producers gary
gary carter a hard time yesterday
because you know he messes with he
messing around with the washington
football team and they had the mvp one
year the kicker okay a kicker
in the national football team the kicker
the 1982 yeah that strikes jordan season
one what's the mvp of the league yeah
that's shameful that's shameful i mean
they should strike that from the record
anyway like there are little blips like
that that happen in football those blips
don't happen in the nba ever but i'll
tell you this and this is what gets my
attention two things one you can be all
nice you can do this little nice thing
with giannis if you want to
i'll bet you giannis feels a little
empty today
now he'll be proud in
in three weeks or a month or a month and
a half there's no way a guy who's a
defensive player of the year
best team in the regular season the
milwaukee bucks mvp of the league and he
has to sit there just like you just like
me and watch the eastern conference
finals when he's got all this hardware
but wouldn't he rather be on the court
so yes he's a little disappointed and
that's okay that's not fair well okay
wait i'm you know i'm a word smith so
i'm gonna parse your word not even parts
i want to focus i'm gonna narrow it on
you said he feels a little empty i don't
know what exactly what that means
because either empty or you're not you
know so i don't know if he feels if he
got mixed emotions or what but how can
you so you're telling me that somebody
who's worked as hard as he has to get
where he is that improves year to year
the way that he does is now i think the
11th guy with back-to-back mvps and you
look at that list you talk i mean that
that's a that's a hell of a list you
know what i mean uh
it's great you're telling me that he's
somehow
isn't as proud of his as you put it
today regular season accomplishment
because he's not playing right now i
think he yes would he like to be playing
right now sure but are you i think two
things can be true at the same time yes
if i'm him of course i am two things to
be true at the same time michael
uh not not to me but okay we disagree on
that but i'll say and here's the other
thing
so when i pointed out that no chumps win
uh nba mvp no trumps win it but it's
just it's pretty i'm pretty curious on
this
only two multiple mvps in the history of
the league only two multiple mvps don't
have championships and i know how you
feel about championships we had our
football argument who's the other one
steve nationally who else
call him alone
oh gorgeous
so so multiple champions see
basketball's different
and and that's how you get respect in
that league
i'm sorry so i don't know if he is going
to be a champion i'll just be
i'll be watching him closely he's got
plenty of time he's not old uh he's not
in decline i'd say he's still ascending
he's got a lot he can add to his game
but i wonder
where he will wind up i'm just that's
just a thought that came into my head
that usually in basketball your multiple
mvps
are not only
getting it done in the regular season
but they usually take that and they
clean up in the postseason
i'm talking about obviously you know
lebron
larry bird michael jordan kareem
abdul-jabbar bill russell throughout the
history of the league if you are a
multiple mvp winner
tim duncan you're also
a champion and i wonder yeah all the
people you named everybody you just
named
they're all done playing except lebron
they're all done playing okay and so
what i would ask you is are you talking
about by the time you've won multiple
mbps or are you talking about just
winning multiple mvps when it's all said
and done he's 25 years old
refresh my memory because you know i'm
not as good on basketball as you are hey
michael jordan won a title by the time
he was 25 he had nothing i think he had
okay so maybe this is part of giannis's
process so to say what he's not going to
be that's why i got so annoyed with my
man richard jefferson talking about i
don't know you know he needs a jordan
he's a pippin i'm like you don't even
know what he is right now because he
lost the playoffs two years in a row
you know what you
i i wonder what's going on you're a
little annoyed today everything's
annoying you isn't your dog is it the
dog stokely car michael cause every time
i want to tell y'all something every you
can't talk to michael smith on the phone
five minutes interrupt he's so annoying
to talk to five minutes
six minutes on the phone you try to talk
to him and it's like you're having this
good conversation all of a sudden it's
like hey
hey hey hey get the dog get the dog get
the dog are you gonna take the dog out
you see your mama doing something else
not everybody not everybody has a
cottage that they can escape
and get peace and quiet in the back of
their house so i mean you know yeah i
got i'm managing a lot of things
in my household right now like i got i
got i got a homeschool daughter five
feet away from me you know i got i got a
son andy i got a dog who who who just
got snipped so he got was coming out
okay
and so you know he's struggling yeah
it's it's hard out here for pimp right
now you know i mean they got a lot going
on
you